bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week-end
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs à vos
idées de sorties nous parlerons
improvisation théâtrale avec
l'association louis signoles qui sont en
représentation ce week-end sans oublier
les rendez vous sportifs ou encore la
chronique cinéma mais tout d'abord place
à notre premier invité
ce week-end le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse propose différentes
activités pour en parler avec nous en
plateau virginie le vote donc chargé
d'animation du parc bonjour bonjour
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu justement les
animations qui seront proposées dans
cette haute vallée de chevreuse alors
pour le week-end des parcs qui est une
opération commune aux quatre parcs
d'ile-de-france en fait on a imaginé un
certain nombre d'animations en cherchant
un peu à mixer le sportif le patrimoine
utiliser toutes les richesses voilà du
territoire en matière de paysages de
nature donc on a des balades en gyropode
qui vont permettre en fait voilà de
circuler au pied du château de la
madeleine d'aller dans le sens de
chevreuse bénéficier de visites
historiques on a des balades en ânes
pour famille donc avec les enfants qui
peuvent pas être sur les années qui vont
faire tout un circuit là aussi à partir
de saint rémy les chevreuse on a ensuite
des balades gourmandes qui vont
permettre de faire une visite de la
chèvre de la chèvrerie de coubertin et
puis dans des dégustations qui vont là
aussi circulé jusqu'au château qui vont
s'arrêter chez un sirop pied qui vient
d'ouvrir à chevreuse un bar à sirop qui
fera des ateliers de confection
artisanale de sirop donc avec des
plantes des fleurs les gens apprendront
à faire leur propre siro naturel donc
quelque chose de très original de très
sympathique et puis on a également la
possibilité ensuite voilà de faire une
visite
autour de maisons insolite du xxème
siècle donc une balade guidée par
l'architecte du parc avec la maison
volante ski à saint rémy les chevreuse
un disciple donc de notre grand
architecte le corbusier et puis ensuite
une maison très original troglodytes à
chevreuse assez peu visitée en général
et qui va être a exceptionnellement
ouvert pour l'occasion donc vraiment
voilà un choix très varié des balades
nature aussi avec une balade en forêt de
poids ni avec une guide de parc qui va
permettre de découvrir la nature au
printemps sur le thème le végétal
pourquoi ça explose pourquoi voilà les
les bourgeons deborah cette période là
une balade plus historique avec les vaux
de cernay et notre guide par jean-paul
car celle qui va faire découvrir tout le
tracé des peintres paysagistes et le
site des petits moulins qui va
prochainement ouvrir aussi au public et
donc il sera un site magnifique à
découvrir
voilà donc un ensemble de ballades doit
faire en tout cas voilà pour tous les
goûts pour tous les âges alors il y en a
beaucoup des ja qui sont complètes il
reste quelques places sur le jeu au
centre d'innovation il reste encore
quelques places alors quelques places
sur le gyropode mais vraiment plus
beaucoup donc là ça va être un test de
rapidité pour les les plus les plus
motivés après c'est vrai qu'on a aussi
voilà sur toute la belle saison on
retrouve des balades équivalente que ce
soit accompagné par un guide de parts
que ce soit à cheval aussi parce qu'on
fait des balades à cheval un peu tous
les mois on va dire ce qu'ils pourront
pas être présents ce week end pour
diverses raisons qui n'auront plus de
place qui n'hésite pas à aller voir sur
le site du parc à s'inscrire à la
newsletter mensuelle ils auront toutes
les infos pour ratez surtout pas les
prochaines opérations d pouvoir suivre
voilà les prochaines animations et donc
c'est gratuit
une très grande partie des animations
sont gratuites notamment la balade
gourmande notamment la balade
architecturale
après une participation pour les balades
en ânes et celle avec le girou aussi
puisqu'il ya un petit peu de matériel ou
d'équipements nécessaires donc voilà
avec des prestataires de la région qui
sont des prestataires locaux qui qui
sont associés à l'opération mais
évidemment avec un petit défraiement qui
fait qu' on a demandé une participation
donc vous le disiez cet événement est
vraiment ouvert à tout le monde tout à
fait on a un territoire voilà qui est
vraiment exceptionnel
un territoire rural avec des paysages
voilà quand on arrive en vallée de
chevreuse même quand on habite tout près
à saint quentin en yvelines ya toujours
un effet de surprise parce que bon on a
des petits villages on a des paysages
ouverts on a une nature qui est très
présente et c'est vrai que on a toujours
envie de la faire connaître davantage
parce qu'il ya tout un potentiel alors
des balades libre à faire gratuitement
des sites historiques magnifique à
visiter enfin malaga vraiment un
potentiel très important et donc ce
week-end c'est l'occasion de mettre un
coup de projecteur sur une offre
d'activités qui est présent toute
l'année mais qu'on met en valeur sûre ce
week-end là en s'appuyant si sûr à
toutes les connaissances aussi de
partenaires de la région c'est vrai
qu'on a des guides historique
passionnant voilà qui vont permettre de
faire des activités on a une activité
sur laquelle il reste encore des places
que j'ai oublié c'est l'atelier
calligraphie au château de la madeleine
dont couplée avec une place ou pas
beaucoup il reste quelques places
restent si cette place donc voilà de
quoi que si on intéressés du coup ça se
passe ça se passe comment il faut numéro
de téléphone du parc 01 30 52 09 09 ou
le site internet direct où il ya des
possibilités d'inscription en ligne et
donc voilà pour les familles l'atelier
calligraphie au château de la madeleine
c'est vraiment avec notre guide
conférencière aurélie ehrlich qui à la
fois quelqu'un très pointue et en même
temps capable de vendre de faire des
animations accessibles de découverte et
d'initiation c'est vraiment un moment
très agréable et vous attendez combien
de personnes sur ce week-end alors la
météo est au rendez vous donc on est
plutôt confiant c'est une opération
commune avec les quatre autres parcs est
porté par la région ile de france avec
un peu toute une campagne donc c'est un
peu l'inconnu parce que c'est simplement
la deuxième édition et l'an dernier on
avait un petit peu testé sur une autre
période avec beaucoup de mauvais temps
donc ce n'était pas forcément dans ce
qu'elle va faire beau pour les ramener
du monde là ça pourrait ramener du monde
voilà on vous dira plutôt combien on a
eu à la fin que combien on attend au
début parce que c'est assez difficile à
prévoir il ya également le salon des
donc des métiers d'art à châteaufort au
galetas fait le salon des métiers d'art
qui est là un rendez vous récurrent
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
qui s'installe au moulin d'or ça château
fort donc là aussi un site très très
jolie au coeur de la réserve naturelle
voilà du domaine d'or sedan dans les
vieilles pierres de ce moulin restauré
par le parc et avec toute une tout un
panel d'activités de métier
avec en plus la particularité cette
année d'avoir centre est un petit peu le
salon autour du recyclage donc en fait
il ya plein de la date d'artisans qui
vont montrer un petit peu ceux qui
recyclent le carton ceux qui recyclent
le plastique pour le transformer en
mobilier en sac enfin voilà et puis des
métiers plus traditionnels mais tout
aussi intéressants les verriers les
ébénistes fin voilà y'a vraiment des
choses magnifiques à voir l'entrée de
ces simplement deux euros par adulte
donc vraiment symbolique et donc voilà
plein de choses à faire des balades
autour des choses passionnantes à voir
donc là aussi voilà un week-end bien
rempli pour se faire plaisir tout à fait
merci virginie le vote est passé sur
notre plateau on espère que le public
donc sera au rendez vous sur ce week-end
ont continué cette édition avec une
autre idée de sortie une exposition à
versailles
elle est décédée dans l'anonymat en 2009
la photographe viviane meilleur est
aujourd'hui célébré pour ses portraits
de gens de la rue les clichés de la
franco-américaine sont à découvrir en ce
moment à versailles à la galerie de
l'école des beaux-arts les images sont
signés patrick jacques de dixmude et
mathilde capbern
des visages inconnus la france des
années 50 vu par l'objectif de vivienne
meyer une photographe décédé dans
l'anonymat en 2009 et qui apparaît
désormais comme l'une des plus
brillantes photographe de rue né à new
york d'une mère française l'artiste
séjourne à plusieurs reprises dans les
hautes-alpes au début des années 50 elle
y réalise un important travail
photographique avec mon modem il attend
ses proches de la rue proche de la
réalité une sensibilité c'est ce qui
nous touche en fait c'est que havas au
plus près d'eux des gens qui sont là
autour de nous et en effet il ya quand
même théâtralité mois donc proche des
photos c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'on sent que c'est pas parce qu'on
fait un instantané on va faire photo pas
composé d'anjou avec des gens qui
passent mais que fait extrêmement
composé
au delà des portraits d'anonymes viviane
mayer aime aussi se prendre en photo
certains experts pensent que c'est une
façon de se voir à travers son
esthétisme et photographiques d'autres
voient cela comme un exercice de style
ces autos par pression tellement précis
que c'était mieux pour régler son
appareil faire des cadrages faire des
plans de l'été sur elle même sur
l'arrière blanc
moi je pense que c'est vraiment un
travail de photographe qu'elle a fait
avec son appareil la galerie de l'école
des beaux-arts a pour volonté de mettre
en lumière les photographes d'inconnus
c'est l'humanisme de deux de ses
photographies umanis d'autant plus
précieux quand on connaît le photographe
et qu'on connaît quand on connaît
l'artiste qui était quelqu'un de
particulier de spécial
et qui à un moment quand alcool et son
oeil à l'appareil photo devenue
quelqu'un d'autre et ça ça rend la
photographie et les photographies que
nous présentons encore plus précieuse
intéressante
viviane mayer réalise plus de 120000
photographie entre 1950 et la fin des
années 80 son exposition est proposée
jusqu'au 23 avril à versailles
voici une autre activité qui ravira les
fans de théâtre et de spectacles ce
dimanche 12 avril à 17h30 l'association
lévis signol propose des matchs
d'improvisation à l'espace culturel
decauville à voisins le bretonneux alors
nous avons enfin philippe verissimo nous
a rejoints en plateau bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes donc le président
déficit alors c'est ça voilà c'est ça
alors pouvez vous nous en dire un peu
plus du coup sûr sur cet événement alors
ben l'événement que c'est le 12 avril à
17h30 à de covin donc à
voisins-le-bretonneux
l'association existe depuis maintenant
une vingtaine d'années on accepte tous
niveaux amateurs professionnels
acceptent également tout âge moi j'ai 21
ans le plus vieux à 55 ans on est plus
d'une trentaine d'arrestations presque
je dirige aussi en atelier junior entre
11 et 16 ans avec laura lee gastaud
c'est nous qui les coaches ont et qu'ils
les entraînons tout au long de l'année
et combien donc c'est cet événement du
coup
ça va être quoi cet événement alors cet
événement ça va pas être un match
d'improvisation classique ça va être un
plus ou moins le concept est plutôt
assez simple en fait ces trois maîtres
de cérémonie qui seront sur scène qui
vont diriger l'impro et toutes les 45
secondes ils vont demander au public
s'ils veulent en voir plus ou moins six
publique dip us l'improvisation continue
normalement s'ils disent - l'imposition
s'arrête et le but évidemment c'est de
faire la plus longue improvisation
possible est ce que ça révèle mans pour
tout le monde oui pour tout le monde
c'est tout public ces 3 euros pour les
mineurs et étudiants et 5 euros pour les
adultes et donc il reste des places ça
pour l'instant ils se déplacent
librement ouais et on fait comment du
concours réservés alors il n'y a pas de
regarder de réservation possible pardon
je conseille au public de venir vers
17h10 17h15 pour être sûr d'avoir des
places et pourquoi pas être au premier
rang et vous pourquoi vous êtes vous
lancé dans l'improvisation alors moi ça
fait onze ans maintenant qu'il en fait
j'ai commencé j'étais plutôt timide en
classe on m'a dit pourquoi pas essayer
le théâtre j'ai essayé de théâtre et
j'étais pas trop à l'aise dedans j'avais
plutôt l'impression reste est une poésie
plutôt que de jouer vraiment et quand
j'ai été voir un match d'improvisation
là je dis mu mais c'est ça que je veux
faire parce que là en fait on est on est
metteur en scène on est comédien à la
fois et c'est exactement ce qui ce qui
me correspond en fait et qu'est ce qui
est difficile justement dans les matchs
d'improvisation
alors dans les matchs c'est assez
particulier vu que c'est une rencontre
quand même de deux équipes n'a pas
forcément le même style de jeu et le but
dans l'impro c'est de jouer avec l'autre
et de jouer pour l'autre aussi ce qui
est difficile je pense au départ c'est
surtout bien avoir une sorte de
d'énergie sur scène de dynamisme et de
réactivité surtout si je pense qu'il
faut être réactif il faut avoir beaucoup
d'imagination et surtout une bonne dose
de dynamisme après ça vient tout seul je
pense et donc il ya un vainqueur à la
fin de cette soirée alors pour le plus
ou moins oui ce sera donc le maître de
cérémonie que raphaël l'impro la plus
longue mais c'est plus une symbolique un
jeu un jeu de scène finalement plus que
n'est pas vraiment un vainqueur
l'objectif c'est quoi de ce spectacle en
l'objectif c'est de faire la plus longue
improvisation possible que le public vu
que c'est public qui choisit si l
improvisation s'arrête ou non
le but ce serait que le public repartent
évidemment ravi vue puisque c'est eux
qui choisissent si ça continue ou pas
donc qu'il soit content finalement de ce
qu'ils voient et est-ce que vous avez un
lien avec déclic théâtre trappe alors
non nous on n'a aucun lien avec déclic
théâtre mais on connaît beaucoup de
personnes on travaille de temps en temps
avec lui on a fait quelques spectacles
pour l'instant on n'a pas de prévu mais
peut-être l'année prochaine peut-être un
match nous rencontrer avec eux merci
philippe verissimo d'être venu sur notre
plateau on veut vous voir à l'oeuvre
donc ce dimanche a donc je rappelle la
date dimanche 12 avril à 17h30 donc à
l'espace de clo villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux tout de suite on
passe à l'actualité à cinéma
on écoute les sorties cinéma de la
semaine et les avis des spectateurs au
micro à d'elodie moines j'ai trouvé ça
bien l'animation est très bien faite
grillen un peu peur pour un moment du
monstre est très bien très bien un petit
peu peur pour la petite mais très bien
c'était bien et est vu attribuer film
déjà été fait
mais est bien c'est pas mal enfin c'est
l'histoire d'une vie quoi c'est un peu
historique soeur ça reprend un peu quand
même la vie un peu comme l'était dans
les années 60 j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
que c'était un très bon film ça change
des rôles différents stand d'habitude
mais très émouvant très sympa à voir
j'ai bien aimé
en fait c'était marrant c'est super bien
fait je trouve et
et
l'histoire en fait ce que ça raconte
quoi à génial super génial
je trouvais que c'était c'était un film
qui était bien réel et touquet qui
parlait de plein de choses qu'on voit
aujourd'hui et je vais m'y emmener mes
petits-enfants
l'ema toujours avec le coup de coeur la
semaine celui de l'udc beaucamp dû
signer cette d'elancourt
alors le coup de coeur du ciné cette
semaine c'est un film français
c'est un thriller qui s'appelle un homme
idéal de yann gozlan avec
l'incontournable on va dire aujourd'hui
pierre niney moi j'avoue que j'ai
découvert l'acteur parce que j'ai pas vu
saint laurent il a tourné aussi dans
d'autres films et je les trouvais
remarquable c'est un thriller français
assez coquin
avec un personnage complètement coincé
dans une histoire dans laquelle il s'est
mis tout seul ça il s'est auto piégé on
va dire bon il ya quelques petites
infractions en blanc ce par nombre de
films mais c'est quand même très réussi
ces deux jolies production avec une
jolie interprétation un scénario encore
une fois avec quelques petits points
d'achoppement m'enfin ça tient quand
même plutôt la route on est dans la peau
du personnage pendant toute la durée du
film on se demande comment il va s'en
sortir
une réussite magistrale
c'est puissant delà de tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer
aujourd'hui jean mathieu ça va faire
trois ans mathieu mais on n'a toujours
rien des gens commencent à se poser des
questions tu sais il faut juste que je
veux travailler certains passages c'est
tout la gym bientôt fini il y avait m
pour vous ce matin
je vais pas raconter la fin évidemment
c'est un thriller il ya beaucoup de
suspense voilà il est à découvrir deux
pour la deuxième semaine sur nos écrans
ou 6,17 à elancourt
on passe à l'agenda sport du week-end en
basket trappe reçoit le mans pour le
dernier match du championnat de
nationale 3 les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi n'ont plus grand chose à espérer
au classement il devrait terminer à une
belle cinquième place après un début de
saison très compliqué si vous voulez les
encourager pour leur dernière sortie le
match est programmé ce samedi à 20
heures au gymnase paul mallet handball
masculin le chine et reçoit beauvais ce
dimanche à 16 heures au gymnase nouvelle
france pour le compte de la 19e journée
de national troyes et chesnaysiens
doivent l'emporter pour rebondir après
leur défaite contre le leader lille une
victoire pourrait leur permettre de
recoller au premier en foot ball trap
reçoit villemomble ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade gilbert gensac les
trappistes 8e de promotion d'honneur
doivent l'emporter pour s'éloigner de la
zone de relégation ils ont fort à faire
face à villemomble qui est actuellement
la cinquième place du classement les
trappistes compte sur le soutien du
public pour les pousser et puis il y
aura du baseball ce week-end et cougar
de montier bretons ne se déplacent ce
dimanche sur le terrain de la rochelle
la rencontre comptera pour la deuxième
journée de deuxième division le baseball
une discipline que nous allons vous
faire découvrir ce lundi à 18h30 dans le
7-8 sport nous avons testé dans cette
émission toutes les facettes de cette
discipline
nous avons réalisé des tirs avec labatt
des exercices pour attraper les balles
la séance a été entièrement supervisé
par l'équipe des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux vous verrez ce
lundi dans le 7-8 sport que ce sport est
loin d'être facile
après la belle au bois dormant le petit
chaperon rouge et le chat botté c'est le
conte de cendrillon qui est mise à
l'honneur au château de breteuil à
choisel c'est la quatrième animation de
son et lumière créé par henri françois
de breteuil qui reçoit en moyenne 500
enfants par jour pour ses spectacles à
reportage de william l
cendrillon rechausse ses souliers au
château de breteuil le célèbre conte de
perrault est mise en scène dans un
spectacle son et lumière de 4 minutes et
c'est juste le temps qu'il faut pour
retomber en enfance
si j'ai choisi cendrillon c'est parce
qu'elle se double aspect de comme je le
disais deux à la fois de la pauvreté et
de la et de la réussite en quelque sorte
par ses belles princesses et puis je
dirais que la seconde raison
c'est la sortie du film de walt disney
qui est magnifique que j'ai vu après le
dessin animé est bien connu l'ag se
trouvait que c'était bien pour breteil
de sortir au même moment que le film
ce spectacle comme un écho au film de
disney a tout de même nécessité trois
mois de travail l'animation des nombreux
personnages étant essentiellement basés
sur les jeux de l'humour c'était le jeu
finalement d'assez complexe il fallait
fabriquer les chevaux il fallait bien
sûr fabriquer le personnage la bande son
fait en studio ensuite la coordination
de la bande son et les éclairages donc
c'était un long et patient travail ici
l'histoire n'est pas racontée en entier
elle s'arrête à la fin du bal lorsque
cendrillon abandonne sa pantoufle
l'occasion de relire la fin en rentrant
chez soi
c'est aussi beau jeu qu'on sait pas ce
qui m'a plu c'est surtout
la façon enfin la rapidité l'abord et
mettre
le papier ensuite imeca marionnettes et
aura même le papier en vitesse c'est
incroyable c'est le quatrième contes de
perrault qui est mis à l'honneur au
château de breteuil l'écrivain ayant été
proche de louis de breteuil à l'époque
contrôleur des finances de louis xiv et
pour profiter du spectacle
rendez-vous tous les dimanches aux
écuries du château avant minuit
évidemment
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour le 7-8 sport passe à un
agréable week-end sur tv fil 78